i don't know if anyone else has noticed
this but if you look up sodium lauryl
sulfate in a clean beauty app it's
usually rated as clean but sodium low
wreath sulfate is usually rated as dirty
these apps are terrible and based on
pseudoscience sls and sles are both safe
in your products
but if you're a skincare nerd you'll
know that sls is considered harsher on
your skin than sles
so
what's with these ratings there's
actually a really interesting story
behind this about an innovation that's
so useful it's everywhere in skincare
hair care beauty but i think most people
have never heard of it i'm michelle of
lab muffin beauty science chemistry phd
and cosmetic chemist and today i'm going
to be talking about the science of
ethosylation how it turned into this
fear-mongering and why you'll probably
hear a lot more of this fear-mongering
over the next couple of years this video
is sponsored by kroda a cosmetics
ingredient supplier who make tons of
ingredients that you find in your
products both voxelated and
non-ethoxylated but as always all the
ingredients in this video are my own
crota did not supply them if you look on
the backs of your products you'll see
this in a lot of ingredient names f a
lot of the time not always these three
little letters means that the ingredient
is ethoxylated their sodium laureth
sulfate of course but there's also
anything that ends in eth and a number
laureth bihini ceteris glyceres
isothionate ingredients there are also
other ethoxylated ingredients too
without the f for example anything with
peg and polysorbates all of these
ingredients are foxylated ethoxylation
means you take an ingredient and you add
little units containing two carbon atoms
that's what the f means in chemistry and
an oxygen which is the oxy part for
example this is the structure of sodium
lauryl sulfate and here is sodium
laureth sulfate you can see the extra
added ethoxylation part this particular
sodium laureth sulfate molecule has two
extra added ethosa units these little
units are really important in changing
the properties of an ingredient most of
these ethoxylated ingredients are
surfactants surfactants have one end
that lacks oil and one end that likes
water they're really important because
if you think about it a lot of skin care
and beauty is about trying to get oil
and water to mix which is the thing that
surfactants are best at for example when
you're cleansing your face or washing
your hair you're trying to get oil to
rinse off into water when you put on a
moisturizer you're trying to add oil and
water to your skin in the one product so
oil and water have to hang out and
behave together nicely a lot of
fragrances are oily but a lot of the
time you have water-based products that
you might want to make fragranced
surfactants are key to making all of
these work the main reason ethoxylation
is so useful is that it adds oxygen to
the structure oxygen is an element with
special properties and the main one is
that it can form special bonds with
water called hydrogen bonds so
ethoxylation will make an ingredient
like water more the more of these ethoxy
units that you add in the more water
loving it'll be
so ethoxylation is really useful for
fine tuning how much an ingredient
prefers water versus oil and therefore
the specific properties of the overall
product the other big impact is that
ethoxylation increases the size of the
surfactant and this means that it
doesn't penetrate skin as easily this
makes this effect much more gentle on
skin and this is why sles is so much
gentler than sls even though they're
both sulfates one study found that sles
could be gentler than sls as well as a
whole bunch of other non-sulfate
surfactants so thanks to ethoscelation
we can have cleansing surfactants that
are gentle on skin but still foam really
well micellar waters with surfactants
that can clean skin effectively but
they're so gentle that you don't need to
rinse them off cleansing bars that apply
like an oil but rinse off cleanly super
fatting agents in cleansers shampoos and
conditioners that act like water-soluble
oils so your skin and hair can be
moisturized and conditioned while still
rinsing clean but here's the catch
ethoxylation is linked with the chemical
1-4 dioxane 1 4-dioxane isn't
intentionally added to your products it
doesn't have a purpose in beauty but
it's formed as a by-product during
ethoxylation and it ends up as a trace
contaminant it hitches a ride along with
the oxylated ingredients that are
purposely added to the product during
the ethoscellation process you're adding
these little ethoxy units with two
carbons and one oxygen to your
ingredient but sometimes instead of
reacting with the ingredient two ethoxy
units will join together and you end up
with this ring and this is one for
dioxane our by-product one for dioxane
is not nice the main concern is that
it's suspected to be a human carcinogen
even though it hasn't been properly
linked to cancer in humans the evidence
that it causes cancer in animals is
strong enough to believe that it could
happen in humans too so it's probably a
good idea not to be exposed to too much
of it there are two ways we can
potentially be exposed to one full
dioxane through our beauty products
firstly when we use products with traces
of 1 4 dioxane most of the 1 4 dioxane
evaporates into the air but some of it
can be absorbed through skin and some of
it could be inhaled cleansing products
like body wash and shampoo have the
highest amounts of 1 4-dioxane not
surprising because they also have the
highest amount of surfactants
surfactants are their active cleansing
ingredients there are also some
differences between how different
ingredients are made that changes how
much one full dioxane ends up in them
sles usually has the highest amounts of
contamination because of how it's made
but the levels of 1 4 dioxane beauty
products have actually dropped a lot
over the years ingredient manufacturers
have been working on reducing the
amounts of 1 4 dioxane without there
being any laws in place there are ways
to produce the methoxylated ingredients
with less 1 4 dioxane and there are ways
to remove a lot of the excess 1 4
dioxane afterwards and these have been
really effective the fda has monitored
how much 1 4 dioxane is in beauty
products from the us over the years in
1981 the average amount was 50 parts per
million which is equivalent to one drop
in a giant one liter bottle of shampoo
by 1997 the average amount had more than
dropped by half to 19 past per million
so a bit less than half a drop in here
in 2008 the fda conducted another survey
of 35 products the highest level
detector was 11.6 parts per million
eighty percent of the products had
levels below one part per million which
is less than one fiftieth of a drop in
this bottle the amount considered safe
in beauty products is slightly different
around the world 10 parts per million is
the limit recommended by the scientific
committee for consumer safety in the eu
this is the amount that they calculated
would cause one extra person in 7.5
million to get cancer per year or the
equivalent increased lifetime risk of
cancer if you smoked half a cigarette
per year for 60 years but like you saw
the vast majority of products don't have
this much anyway so you don't have to be
all ewg about it new york recently
changed their laws to limit one full
dioxane in cosmetics to 10 parts per
million by the end of 2022 but they've
gone further with household cleaning and
personal care products the ones that you
rinse off your skin one for dioxane in
these will be limited to two parts per
million by the end of 2022 and one part
per million by the end of 2023
so why do the things that don't stay on
our skin have tighter limits
well it's because of the other and
overall bigger concern one for dioxane
is a drinking water contaminant and this
is a very real problem one for dioxane
absorbs easily from your digestive
system a lot of places do have quite
high levels of dioxane in their drinking
water and most places don't have laws on
the allowed level of 1 4 dioxane so the
idea is cosmetics stay on your body but
personal care products which is defined
as cleansing products including shampoo
conditioner soap and bath products
these go down the drain into the
waterways which eventually becomes
drinking water so i guess limiting 1 4
dioxane in personal care products does
make sense in theory
but i'm skeptical it's going to do much
1 4 dioxane is a trace contaminant in
personal care products but it's used
intentionally in much larger quantities
in other industries it's a solvent
that's used in paints inks cleaning
making plastics one for dioxane was most
commonly used as an additive to
stabilize chlorinated solvents which
were phased out as part of the montreal
protocol also known as the one time the
world actually got together and did
something about an environmental
disaster the montreal protocol banned
the use of substances that destroyed the
ozone layer and the main chlorinated
solvent that 1 4 dioxane was used with
was banned in 1996 so the use of 1 4
dioxane has actually dropped massively
from its peak in the 80s in the u.s it's
dropped to about 125th of the amount
used at the peak but every year about 1
million pounds which is
half a million kilograms if you're in a
country that uses real numbers
that much dioxane is used every year and
in 2016 62 000 pounds which is 28 000
kilograms of that was released into the
water so we can do a calculation to work
out how much shower gel and shampoo
you'd have to use to release that amount
of dioxane into the water if your
products have an average of two parts
per million every single person in the
u.s would have to rinse 43.5 liters of
beauty products down the drain every
year that is about one-third of this mug
or 24 palm-sized dollops of product
every day and even then these amounts
that are currently released by industry
every year aren't thought to be the
biggest contributor to 1 4-dioxane in
drinking water the amounts of 1-4 dioxin
used decades ago before chlorinated
solvents were phased out were much much
higher there are lots of old industrial
areas and improperly lined disposal
sites that are contaminated with one for
dioxane and this can leach into
underground water which is where a lot
of our drinking water comes from a 2017
study found that dioxane in contaminated
water was correlated with chlorinated
solvent levels and this points towards
the old industrial uses as the main
culprit in new york where this law is
being introduced supposedly to improve
drinking water it's long island that has
particularly contaminated water and it's
thought that it's because there are lots
of old industrial sites there and their
drinking water comes from underground
aquifers so to me it seems like a much
better approach would be to treat the
industrial sites either way these new
limits are coming in at the end of the
year in new york so i think this whole
thing is a really interesting story that
highlights a lot of themes that come up
a lot in
the beauty discourse firstly really
amazing innovations can become a victim
of their own success things that get
really popular also get really
scrutinized and if there's any sort of
fear-mongering that can be done you know
that certain sections of the beauty
industry are going to try their best to
take advantage of it crystal ball time
i think we're probably going to see some
1-4 dioxin scare stories around the end
of the year when these restrictions
start taking place which will be a great
christmas present for me i also think
that other places will make similar
changes because theme number two
sometimes the easy things get regulated
and the hard but more important things
get ignored sometimes maybe lawmakers
genuinely don't understand the issue but
sometimes this can be a strategic
decision to look like they're doing
something it acts as a smoke screen for
inaction setting a limit that
manufacturers have to meet is cheap and
easy but remediating industrial sites is
a lot harder new york is going to
evaluate whether this law actually
worked in 2025 and i do think they'll
say it did because dioxane's actually
been going down anyway plus scientists
are developing lots of ways of getting
dioxane out of wastewater and drinking
water i hope someone will do an analysis
to see if the personal care product
limit will make a difference because i
could be wrong plus the beauty industry
does proactively do good things without
being forced to by specific regulations
the catch is that a lot of it does
depend on what they feel like consumers
want so we need to be asking for the
right things not things that are based
on misunderstandings of what the real
issues are one of the really exciting
things happening in the industry is that
a lot of ingredient suppliers are coming
out with sustainability innovations and
these will probably filter down to us
over time for example crota's eco with
oscillator surfactant range this is 100
bio-based and renewable and made with
renewable energy so there's less
reliance on fossil fuels a lot of the
time going more natural can mean that
it's more resource intensive but these
eco ingredients still have a lower
carbon footprint than the petrochemical
versions these still perform as well as
those versions and of course they all
have low 1 4 dioxane i'm going to stick
these predictions behind the code behind
me someone remind me to check at the end
of the year links to more videos should
be coming up if you want to keep
watching